how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to the channel first of all
want to say thank you to everybody who
has wished me at well recovery with my
broken foot I deeply appreciate it and
second of all we have a lot of Marvel
news to talk about today from Hawkeye to
Black Panther to n inhuman possibly
coming to the MCU and Eternals there's
lots of news to break down so let's dive
right into it if you're new be sure to
subscribe but with notifications turned
on to stay up to date on everything
relating to the MCU and there are
giveaway details at the end of this
video so most of this news is for phase
4 so it involves the next couple of
years coming up and let's start off with
Hawkeye news because there's been a lot
going around recently with it being
delayed last month there was a report
that the Hawkeye series was delayed
indefinitely which meant that it may not
ever happen but now we have some good
news according to Charles Murphy the
production for the Hawkeye series is no
longer delayed it has simply been pushed
back a few months and according to him
Marvel Studios is eyeing to start the
Hawkeye series production in September
and if not September definitely by the
end of the year and this means a late
2021 release date which basically lines
up with what Kevin Feige said when he
announced it for fall of 2021
and according to this report nobody has
been cast yet for Kate Bishop although
Marvel Studios and Disney are still
eyeing Hailee Steinfeld for the role and
they hope that they can work something
out so great news for the Hawkeye series
it is moving forward which is awesome
because many fans are very excited about
the show including myself and then we
have two reports from the Illuminati
calm about she-hulk
and a possible inclusion of an inhuman
and according to the report she Hulk is
in the preliminary casting phases and
although the script isn't 100% complete
yet the studio intends to shoot the
series in Atlanta beginning in August of
this year lasting until March of 2021
and there's a little bit of confusion
about the three late Disney Plus shows
that were announced at Disney's d23
event moon night she-hulk and Miss
Marvel are going to be in phase four or
if they're going to be in phase five
well if the production of she hold is
going to end in March of 2021 then that
probably means that it's going to take
place in Phase five and 2022 because if
you look at the end of the year 2021 and
the end of phase four it's pretty packed
already
we have the Loki series Marvel's what-if
series Hawk
and Thor love and thunder so it would be
hard to squeeze another project in at
the end of 2021 so we can probably
expect she-hulk at phase 5 and then
there's a report about an inhuman coming
and Miss Marvel there's a casting call
that went out for Miss Marvel and it
lists for two male Muslim supporting
characters who are in the 17 to 25 year
old range the first character is pretty
familiar from the comics and that is red
dagger and it's explained that there is
an undeniable romantic connection
between him and Camilla so we already
have Camilla's love interest right there
but then the second one is Camryn and he
is described as having a friendship with
kamila and her family he initially
attempts romance with Camilla but he is
also being described as a morally
corrupt inhuman and the term morally
corrupt and human is very specified for
those of you who may not know who
Cameron is he's an inhuman with the
ability of biokinetic charged using the
stored energy within his body
Cameron can channel that energy by
discharging it as a shock or by
transferring that energy into an object
causing it to glow and then explode so
according to the casting call for Miss
Marvel we are getting Cameron and
inhuman in Miss Marvel and then we have
some quick Eternals news it has been
reported that ser Z and Black Knight are
going to be the main characters of the
show which most of us knew but it's nice
to get a confirmation but the most
interesting news we got this week is
about Black Panther and Doctor Strange
multiverse of madness it's been reported
by a few different websites including
cosmic bug news.com that a female
version of Black Panther will show up in
Doctor Strange multiverse of madness and
this female version could be Shuri
now obviously T'Challa is not passing on
the mantle of the true Black Panther
anytime soon so the Shuri that we could
see as Black Panther is probably going
to be from a different universe
considering this is the multiverse of
madness and Doctor Strange is going to
explore different universes and
alternate realities which means he's
going to run into alternate versions of
some of these characters and apparently
one of the characters is going to be a
female version of black panther that is
supposed to be a Shuri
which is interesting because with Doctor
Strange in the multiverse of madness you
can almost do a what-if we know marbles
do in an animated what-if series but
when dr. strange visits a different
reality it's almost
like things could have happened
differently if this happened so it's
almost like it's very own what-if and in
this case of this report it's a what-if
Sheree was black panther and not to
chala so that's something to look for as
Doctor Strange begins pre-development
and as we find out more about it so
phase 4 is well underway a lot of
exciting things coming out very very
soon let me know what you're most
excited for it in the comments down
below and again don't forget to like the
video and subscribe and notifications
turn on so you can enter my giveaway for
a chance to win an Xbox one or a ps4
that when it gets to choose and I'm
picking a winner at five hundred and
fifty thousand subscribers as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof woof